hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to whack the cheater now
this has been an unbelievably requests
game and I can understand why
considering the other games that I
played in the past but this is not made
by the same person that did the last
ones or either one of them that did the
last one so this is different I don't
know probably gonna be bloody and brutal
because that's what people said in the
parent that's what people want so like
the other ones you click on things and
then horrible things happen
oh no you cheated on me how dare are you
I'm leaving well that's about the law
why'd you kill both of them was the
point rather no sound effects in the
game sound effects in the last one oh
this is not a healthy exercise to do you
know what wait he literally put her in
the way and then she continued to beat
up her why is she feeding up her I'm
assuming that's her husband there that's
cheating on her why is the lady getting
beat up is it her fault
boy okay alright then whatever this is
is that a pizza or brick oh no
everything's gone horribly wrong
I better take my angle why why again why
why why is that a big oh man I don't
know if anyone's been cheated on before
I've been cheated on before but I mean
it's just like why why why would you
attack the one that isn't the one you
okay oh you know this would be lovely
with some sound effects in it
yeah that's what you know why why why
what is the point what what are you
doing she just murdered someone and
you're gonna go crawling back to her
that doesn't make any sense
this game doesn't make any sense this
game is illogical in every way it's
almost as if people don't regularly even
though that does happen Oh Oh finally
the right target oh but I think what
what
[Music]
okay at least that one didn't involve
murder great I'm so happy for everyone
involved in this terrible scenario why
do I play the whitey you guys want me to
play these games god they're just
there's just a brutal exercise in
futility an illogical miss how about a
stop yield sign okay
kicked in the nards that's good what
what what I got over so quickly and I
still see the sign there skate
missiological
in a lot of ways but mostly because I
don't actually understand what the
hell's going on
oh yes broken umbrella why not oh well
[Music]
no that's a brown yeah oh that's it
furred how about this one I'm sure this
one is gonna be a welcome change
[Music]
you know without sound effects and
because there's copyrighted music
playing right now this is very
disturbing on a different level than
before
why doesn't make any sense why your
aggression is misguided I don't
understand I don't understand I don't
understand why oh oh she fought back oh
cool
maybe I don't know not cool
it's so weird it's like watching some
horrible art film let me go off together
[Music]
after that I die you know what I don't
even think I can't understand this I got
9 out of 12 I don't know how much more I
want to play of this game did that click
on that box
boom I don't know what that oh why why
what she shattered to pieces going into
a box and died physiological
everything's illogical what I imagine is
going on here is this is like some dream
or fantasy if someone who's been cheated
on and it's like yeah I'm gonna take all
my gresham out on that [ __ ] that stole
my man but it's like it's your man the
runoff water you okay I don't know if
I'm lost but I can only get 10 out of 12
and I don't know how to find that other
ones
frankly I don't have to be subjected to
this I had a great day why don't I have
to be subjected to the emotions of
someone who's compromised like my
goodness this is just so wrong that
somebody goes one don't kill people
that's a markiplier life lesson right
there - if you're being cheated on play
your aggression in the direct you know
right direction and don't kill people
refer to Margo our life lesson number
two or one one to two and number three
wounds oh I don't know about this game
guys I don't know baby it was requested
I knew what people because I'm doing for
you to play with it by a boat hey by a
thread but either way thank you
everybody so much for watching you can
check out the other wack my games in the
annotations are in the description over
there if you want to see more of them at
least the other ones were kind of funny
this one was just brutal and horrible
but yes you guys some someone had to
have fun about it so thank you everybody
so much for watching click the end
today's more videos
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next video bye
[Music]